it's my birthday happy birthday to me
happy every house camera and it's my
birthday today but it's not when you
watch his videos there's no point in
saying had worked in the comments and
yours eating my bracelet how dare you
we're leaving to the airport in like one
hour and I wanted to say it's gonna be
awesome because I've been preparing
videos for like two and a half weeks I
can't wait to get on a plane and just
relax it's gonna be awesome
ken is gonna be in LA we're gonna go to
the Enders game premiere also which is
awesome I'm really looking forward to
it's gonna be a fun trip oh you okay
then Maya Maya say something to the
camera
I'm asleep I'm going out to get
breakfast me and my seven awake for
three hours or something I'm starving so
she she threw me out to get her
Starbucks there's a lot of youtubers in
LA at the moment so I'm looking forward
to hang out
everyone is jogging it's crazy like why
would they move God like that what's
wrong with people I'm gonna get food and
get fat okay we're heading out now for
the Enders game behind the scene we're
gonna look at some special effects and
how it's made for the movement stuff
like it should be pretty awesome I'm
pretty excited for it so let's go
I'm super excited for the movie now
great yeah we could go so me and Marcel
were invited for an exclusive tour of
the Ender's games visual effects it was
so cool I got to sit down with that
director of the film as well as visual
effects supervisor artist and stunt
coordinator of the film and they all
came in on a Saturday just to do this
tour with me and I was just blown away
by it
here's a clip from the battle room which
is kind of like a three-dimensional
football field but in space and as you
can see they only end up using the
actors face in the final result just to
perfect as much as possible and it gives
you an idea how much they actually put
into detail and I thought that was
pretty awesome this is the greatest song
I've done Oh Kurt hands down vol hasn't
done very much that I've done I've done
it too I've got a few projects you know
and you know I would venture to say I'll
bet my left eye but this is some of the
greatest practical flying that you'll
ever start any film okay out there on
this world cool I move my arms around
like this my here's the visual effects
supervisor explaining how they manage to
mimic zero-g and if you look closely in
this shot you can actually see how much
I understand of it what a complex
challenge I kind of unwittingly through
if these guys alright and I'm very proud
of the way it all came together
literally hundreds of layers of shots
you want to be in here and play around
with it yeah yeah I want to put I won't
put you in this game I have a lot to I
think we need to do jack we need to take
images of him and put him instead ender
oh I'm okay with this we can hear and we
rip
face in this face with yours you can put
you it again you out but yeah we were
trying to create a super cool video game
so god help us if you don't like it so
we just got back from the
behind-the-scenes tour and like I've
said a million times already it was it
was very cool I'm gonna be so biased now
when I actually watched the film I'm
gonna love it anyway because they were
so nice and so cool to hang out with
it's really thanks to you rose that I
can go I even get the opportunity to go
and stuff like this so I I really
appreciate it thank you brass thank you
it's so it's so awesome thank you really
what about your bows are you excited to
see the movie have you have you read the
book let me know and me and Weiss I
gonna go now we're gonna take over LA
mouth I'm gonna try to record another
longer vlog for you bros but until then
stay awesome
you